inside the rise of anti-work a workers
strike that wants to turn the labor
shortage into a new american dream
this is like the article that bloomberg
ran that said hey the stores don't have
any stuff in them maybe that's good
and you know bloomberg the guy who runs
bloomberg is mike bloomberg
billionaire look up mike bloomberg's net
worth it's like 70 billion dollars or
more
this is the guy that ran for president
uh 59 billion wow well he's in the
middle class i forgot
59 billion dollars
he runs the publication and bloomberg is
saying they have this article you should
find the article where it's basically
like hey americans may need to live like
europeans and that's pretty damn cool
maybe that's not the worst thing that
you go to the store and the
shelves are half full
yeah supply chain shortages are
constraining you as consumers endless
appetite for buying whatever they want
whenever they want it's about time yeah
like eggs
the endless appetite for things
after all americans haven't always acted
like this we've entered an age of
overabundance we consume much more than
we used to and more than other countries
so they're kind of shaming us and too
well here's the deal
we absolutely consume too much we're too
fat we eat too much the houses are too
big everything's too big but
the way to fight that probably is some
type of spiritual renaissance where
people realize that consumption in and
of itself is uh ultimately empty and
hollow and then they need to involve
themselves in more meaningful activities
where they can get more out of life uh
that's the hard way to do it and the
sustainable way uh just walking into a
store and not having things
doesn't seem like a real
people are still going to consume just
whatever they can find
these are also the people that go
uh fat is great you eat whatever you
want whenever you want it and then
they're like maybe americans should
start living like europeans well you
know what that means not being fat slobs
but i thought that was good
fatness is good it's not unhealthy don't
think it being 500 pounds is healthy and
great and beautiful
and everybody will how do you get to be
500 pounds
consuming [ __ ]
so if you say well we should stop
consuming what do you mean by that do
you mean americans should stop buying
treadmills
no you mean that people should like hey
how about one loaf of bread for the week
for the family that's kind of how i read
it you don't need all the new gadgets
and gizmos
a lot of them food
related but
it's weird to get this article from
bloomberg
it's weird of a bunch of billionaires go
yeah the stores are bare
the prices of gas is up so just drive
less
hey you can't afford gas maybe you
should uh don't go there
that place you want to go
why don't you go to hey you want to go
see your mother c or less
it's very condescending and strange to
tell people that they should adjust
their habits when billionaires and
people worth hundreds of millions of
dollars have only gotten richer have
only bought more jets
have only bought more property can only
do more things and people that aren't in
that bracket can't do anything and those
people are told it's good
they tell people to go on long bike
rides rather than just drive because go
on a bike ride with your kids
on the highway
take your children on a bike ride on the
side of the road and go to the grocery
store it's good for you maybe you'll all
die
and we could stop here in your mouths
whitney webb is coming back on to talk
about this
the great reset
and i know that a lot of people have
dismissed that as a conspiracy and maybe
parts of it are but saying that this is
restructuring the economy is not a
conspiracy it seems pretty damn accurate